disclaimer I own nothing hey there
fellow nerds and dorks alike this is a
quick video I wanted to put out to give
some fast speculation before there isn't
time to speculate so let's get this all
done quick we all know Tom Hollands
spider-man will be in Captain America
Civil War something I've noticed in the
marketing best far as they refuse to
show what the suit will look like and I
want mm-hmm pictures of spider-man as
much as the next newspaper publisher but
it looks like they're keeping him as far
under wraps as Luke Skywalker in episode
7 only difference is that we know
spider-man is filmed two fight scenes
and they've already built a set for what
his bedroom will look like so he's going
to have a larger role in the film than
quiet makes a Nothing pants over there
but what will the costume look like it's
probably the second most important part
of the character after making sure the
casting is done well the Sam Raimi
version looked like spider-man but I
hated the raised webs and I wish they
weren't bright silver and the first one
from the amazing spider-man series
looked all right sort of unfinished but
I guess that was the idea the best so
far is the suit from amazing spider-man
2 that's probably the closest they've
gotten it and it's really the only
positive thing I can think of in that
film but they can't just copy that suit
design for Civil War can they it will
confuse the brand and make it hard for
casual moviegoers to distinguish the new
guy from the Andrew Heathcliff version
so many pictures have run across the
internet and all of them turned out to
be fake or just scrapped concept art
what we know so far is that according to
the director it will be very classic
Spidey and will look close to how we
imagined so you mean to tell me that
spider-man is going to look like
spider-man in the movie well who would
have guessed that we know from this that
it won't be the stupid-ass Iron Man
costume that we all know he was going to
stop wearing eventually other details
surfaced that it will have this big
cartoony original spider-man logo on it
actually like that because the previous
ones use this angular sharp design
because some idiot got it in their head
that spider-man has to look threatening
or something so that's about it we don't
know much else about what it will look
like and the directors of being weird
and evasive about in interviews there is
hope though on the website merch I calm
a line of Civil War merchandise was put
together and the pages pictures of
everything except this so a Spider Man
hoodie isn't present yet much like the
character himself mer joy later released
a statement and said ok comma so here's
the deal : we have photos of the Spider
Man hoodie coming very soon period we
really really want to show it to you now
but we're not allowed to just yet make
sure you check back on the 15th of
January for your very first look what's
the significance of January 15th you ask
well it's Friday this week there's
nothing else important about it nothing
really big is happening on that day but
for whatever reason they can't show us
the hoodie until then mystery over
everybody let's just wait a few days and
be patient it's nothing worth talking
about right now
okay just kidding on Sunday I came
across this low resolution picture not
sure who leaked it or how but it looks
pretty legit later in the night I found
out it was leaked by someone on Twitter
and I gotta say I'm happy with the way
it looks I mean it's a pixelated piece
of crap but that's better than waiting a
few days for a 1080p photo my word I'm
not a betting man but I'm gonna go ahead
and guess that whatever happens on
Friday
if anything happens on Friday will be an
official first look at the suit could be
some kind of new trailer or it could
just be a still image like the one from
the Deadpool movie either way let's get
hype well let's analyze this a little it
looks like the gauntlets aren't
connected to the shoulder piece with a
red webbing layer which is design
element first used by the ultimate
spider-man cartoon from 2013 I hate that
show by the way but I'll talk about that
another time the webs are strewn all
over in no particular pattern which
reminds me of the suit design from the
game spider-man edge of time and the big
spider on the chest actually looks navy
blue like the rest of the suit then
again I'm colorblind so I could just be
talking out of my derriere on that
subject so overall it looks pretty good
I'm happy with it
if the suit does end up looking like
this it will be recognizable as
spider-man but still different enough
from the other suits good on you Marvel
you managed to not screw up this costume
design but don't think I've forgotten
about Hawkeye's costume or baron zemo's
mask scarlet witch's costume Madame
masque mask arnim zola's whole body
Loki's helmet Thor's helmet the
mandarins everything and all of her
Queen's beard